ça c'est pas maman de ma bien passé pas
d'inquiétude pour ses jeunes parents ils
travaillent tous les deux et ce n'est
pas un problème puisqu'ils peuvent
confier leurs enfants à cette micro
crèche ouverte à 6h30 le lundi jusqu'au
samedi 8 heures du matin
c'est vraiment ça qu'on recherchait et
il y en a très très peu disponible déjà
avec ses horaires là donc c'est parfait
pour nous je travaille en micro crèche
donc du coup je voyage je connais la les
avantages de mettre un enfant me protège
donc du coup là déjà il y avait une
restriction sur notre recherche de modes
de garde
comme dans toutes les micro crash
l'effectif maximal est de dix enfants
âgés de 2 mois à 3 ans mais sa
particularité ce sont ces horaires
d'ouverture un service de garde non-stop
en dehors du week-end et surtout sur
mesure par rapport aux contraintes de
travail des parents
ça peut être des contrats de cinq jours
ça peut être des contraintes deux jours
et demi d'une demi-journée du ponctuel
donc on a trente huit enfants inscrits
en file active au niveau des deux
structures
cette microcrèche est en effet la
deuxième créé par alice va dès la
première en 2003 et celle ci qui a
ouvert le 19 août dernier et qui ne
suffit déjà plus la société a évolué et
beaucoup de jeunes parents ont des
horaires atypiques on a une amplitude
horaire de 6h45 jusqu'à 22h30 23h voire
même des fois des horaires de nuit donc
c'est vrai que cette crèche elle
correspond tout à fait à nos besoins de
nombreuses demandes sont sur liste
d'attenté et le succès de cette micro
crèche unique en côte d'or à ce jour
pourrait bien servir de modèle je suis
beaucoup sollicités par des futurs
porteurs de projets qui
ils entendent de parler des structures
via les réseaux sociaux et qui me
sollicitent pour savoir comment je m'y
suprise qui sont un peu en difficulté
qui ne savent pas quelles démarches
effectuées donc moi je les accompagne
volontiers analyse bad et envisage de
son côté l'ouverture d'une troisième
structure mais pas tout de suite
[Musique]